All right,
welcome back to Computer Vision.
Last time, we introduced
the notion of image motion.
We said how motion is actually a,
a construct of your head,
because there's just a bunch
of static frames, and
your mind your brain induces this notion
of believing that there's actual motion.
So the question then becomes,
how do we compute that motion?
And we talked about motion
estimation techniques are,
are going to be
the methods of doing this.
The first one that we mentioned
was featured-based methods,
where you detect, describe and locate
features in your subsequent frames.
And we've done a bunch of that in
looking at how we do the sift stuff and
panoramas and those kinds of things.
But the other methods were
called direct or dense methods,
and that's what we're going
to be focusing on today.
Direct and dense methods,
what they do is they recover motion at
every pixel in the image and
that gives you a dense flow feel.
And it is based upon what we call the
spatial temporal brightness variations,
how the appearances is moving and
it's changing.
It can be sensitive to appearance
changes but as long as you're getting
sort of, video like sequences where
you have frames sampled regularly and
frequently, it works pretty well